hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
prudencia's poem psychomachia or the
battle for the soul begins indeed with a
set of combats the first three are
definitely single combats
the
fourth the one that involves pride and
humility
you could look at it as a single combat
although there's assistance and tripping
up that goes on from some helpers you
could say
and as we go on these combats get a
little bit more and more complex they
begin with a very straightforward one
faith versus worship of the old gods
and you know faith very quickly takes
care of that then we have chastity
versus lust and we're seeing more
elements coming in with speeches getting
made we have a very interesting one of
patience versus wrath or you could say
wrath against wrath as well
and then we have pride coming on the
scene giving a big bombastic speech
and not getting hoist by its own petard
but rather the biblical metaphor falling
into a pit
intended for one's
enemies
and
each of these is representing a a battle
a machia within
the soul of the person and so each of
these virtues is fighting against a vice
a good disposition
a good
motivation and set of actions is
fighting against a bad one and so we
lead off like i said with faith fides uh
he tells us faith is the first to appear
on the field to face the uncertainty of
this conflict so at the beginning of the
poem we don't know how this is going to
turn out within the human soul and faith
is
fighting against
the first adversary worship of the old
gods
and worship of the old gods is vatra
cultura de orum so what we have here is
christianity and what's best
in pagan antiquity that's been absorbed
into christianity fighting against the
rest of pagan antiquities religious
beliefs
and this happens you know this combat is
over very quickly faith strikes the
enemy's head it tumbles into the dirt
where it lies
and then faith tramples ahead takes
particular pains to squeeze the dead
gray eyes out of the bloody skull the
monster's throat is dosed its breath is
throttled in its passages the spectators
become brave enough uh to face the foe
and faith crowns her followers with
blossoms and give them gives them robes
of flaming purple so there's a lot going
on here already in this combat is this
like just within the soul of a person
well it's it's supposed to be there but
it's also you know there's all these
spectators as well so
then we get the next one and this is a
bit more complicated chastity
buddha kittiyah
is going to face off against lust
so we have chastity the virgin shining
in armor
lust come from sodom armed with torches
and this time it's the vice that attacks
first the vice thrusts of burning pine
knot dipped in sulfur and
tar into the maiden's eyes so what we've
got here is chemical warfare of a sort
right
and uh chastity strikes the hand with a
stone and the torch is knocked away and
then after that she has a sword and with
the sword she stabs lust libido right
she pierces the throat of the horror and
stinking fumes with clots of blood or
spat forth the foul breath poisons the
nearby air then we get the first of the
speeches the victorious queen
or chastity rather
cries out
this is this will be your end you will
always lie prostate
never again will you dare to split your
flames against the men and women who are
gods and so what's being promised here
is with christianity and in particularly
with a certain kind of agency that comes
from key figures
in in the christian framework
lust which was previously reigning
supreme
can no longer affect these
christians and first she talks about the
head of whole fairness right so this is
actually a
going back to the jewish scriptures uh
holofernes is killed by judith
um
weak the woman though she was her hand
never trembled as she fought for my
cause the cause of chastity with
heavenly boldness
then she goes on and she says because a
woman acted under the old law physical
law maybe you thought she and others
like her would be powerless now that the
battle has been moved to spiritual
realms and she says well guess again a
virgin bore a child so who's she talking
about she's talking about
mary um
here we go a bride who never a wife
conceived the christ who is both man
because of his mother and god because he
was conceived by the spirit of god ever
since that day
all flesh is god-like since it conceives
the son of god and assumes his nature by
a compact
of
partnership so this means that lust
can be disabled if if human beings
choose to embrace
chastity
after that
we have a third combat this is between
long and long enmity or patience
paciencia in the the latin
and who is fighting against pozientia
era wrath anger
wrath spies the easy tempered virtue and
all at once becomes enraged so wrath
gets angry wrath is the personification
of anger and as we're going to see this
is going to have some very interesting
consequences so
first wrath throws a spear at patience
and then throws some language saying
this is for fools like you who stand
aside and watch the combat without
expressing favor take this wound in your
gentle breast without crying you would
be dishonored to bear any pain a kind of
nonsensical speech actually but typical
of an angry person throws the shaft of
pine through the air the shaft strikes
against the belly of patients but falls
into the dust why because the virtue has
wrapped her body in a jacket of steel
links three layers in thickness stitched
together with
leather and wrath keeps throwing more
and more darts and javelins and spears
until wrath is more or less exhausted
then she comes to close combat and
attacks as well
the ground is littered with weapons she
reaches for a sword raising the steel
blade high over her head she brings it
down on the head of patience but a
helmet of forge bronze only rings under
the great blow the sword
its edge blunted rebounds the unbending
helmet shatters it and patience still
stands there unmoved as she as she was
before
this
even greater
angers
this this personification of anger or
wrath and what do we find happening
wrath the fury is multiplied she throws
the the sword aside finds herself
without weapons
one thing remains
her unreasoning anger turns on herself
and she prepares for suicide she picks
up one of her useless weapons she puts
the shaft in the dirt and falls on the
upturned point patience then gives a
little speech and says we have conquered
with no danger to life our accustomed
virtue has won the day again
this is the the way we live wiping out
the devils of passion and all their
attendant evils
by standing as they attack
wrath is its own enemy fury kills itself
so the way to
fight against wrath is not to fight
against wrath you let the wrath exhaust
itself against patience
then we get to the most complex of the
early combats
we got pride now pride
interestingly enough
is viewed by many early christian
authors as the the most problematic of
the sins or vices
because it can take anything else and
turn it into something bad pride is
riding around on a high spirited horse
all inflated by her own great importance
you notice that pride is prideful about
pride and there's some great imagery
here she laid a lion's pelt across the
horse's strong shoulders so she can look
more
important she's braided her hair high on
her head so there could be a lofty and
more imposing peak and it goes on and on
and on a horse the charger who could not
stand still right and so what does she
do she she goes back and forth and then
she you know is looking she's eyeballing
lowliness or humility
um
not paciante um
humilitas right
so pride is superbia this this worst of
sins and then she gives a speech
what kind of nonsense is this
surely you must be ashamed to challenge
so famous someone in seoul famous as me
with troops so tattered how can you
raise your swords against a tribe of
such distinction whose skill at fighting
is one at wealth and give it power to
rule the richest lands you know i i'm
pride who who are you you're nothing
right what army is this that has come
from god uh
you know you lack spirit luck elegance
and good sense the rights you claim have
been assigned to those who claim them
first and she goes she goes on and says
you know must we enter combat with a
chorus of girls with whom are the
beggars justice and honesty parch
sobriety fasting with her pasty you know
white face purity in her bloodless
cheeks simplicity exposed every injury
and lowliness
always bent double to the ground without
freedom and so distressed one must see
her cheap spirit she's basically saying
i am the warrior
you are crap i'm going to pound i'm
going to pound you into submission
and what does she do she charges with
her war horse
and then something happens
and this i mean it's really quite funny
the way that it's brought in here and
there's a lot of different things going
on there is a biblical motif that comes
from the psalms in particular
where the psalmist
is praying that those who are digging a
pit for the psalmist the just person
will fall in the pit themselves
something like that happens
except in this case it's a
helper who's not helpful but actually
harmful deceit
dolos has dug a pit for patients
thinking that patients is going to
attack deceit
saw the war about to break out touch the
earth so the enemy would be caught in
the rush of their attack against the
lines of the vices she camouflaged the
pit with branches overlaid with sod
lowliness had not yet ordered her troops
to advance and engage their foe instead
it's impetuous pride who gallops into
the trap made for lowliness
the horse and pride fall into the pit
the she clings to his mane and is thrown
among his thrashing legs the
self-contained virtue lowliness or
humility
finding her opponent crushed walks
calmly to her side raises her face a bit
combines a look of kindliness with her
joy she refuses to do anything more so
it's interesting here
lowliness by itself
won't actually
do in pride but it will at least hold it
back
it's hope
space
who hands
lowliness or humility a sword and says
take care of this
take care of this job
and so lowliness then grasps the bloody
flow by the by the hair drags her art
out turns her the face towards her own
pride asks for mercy but lowliness bends
the head back cuts it from the body and
raises the gray face for everyone to see
and then hope not lowliness speaks to
those around this is the end this is
what your grand words produce god
shatters arrogance
even the great must fall
inflated pride must be
flattened and again
there's biblical uh imagery and
personages brought in here how well we
know the word of christ that the lowly
will rise to high places is from the
gospel right
and then there's a reference to the
mighty goliath being felled by an
infant's hand a little stone from a
sling struck a hole deep in the forehead
of the giant at his pride so goliath is
a stand-in for pride
as at his prides raging and preening
himself threatening the sky with his
shield
one instant taught him what a child's
toy
might do i hope led that boy into battle
from that day his courage ripened in my
service his mature spirit was part of me
so it's pride uh being brought down in
part by another vice to see it but also
by hope and humility
working together
and these are the first four combats
things are looking pretty good by this
point in the psychomachia
virtues four
vices zero
and we'll have to see what happens next
you